nouvel objet de discorde entre policiers
et soutien de la famille traoré
cette fresque en hommage à georges floyd
et adama traoré inauguré le 18 juin en
présence du maire de ce temps tout en
haut du dessin l'intitulé contre les
violences racistes et policière une
inscription prise comme une provocation
par les forces de l'ordre
le week-end dernier le syndicat alliance
93 avaient appelé à un rassemblement
devant la fresque déclenchant une vive
polémique sur les réseaux sociaux pour
finalement renoncé hier une victoire
pour le comité la vérité pour à damas
qui appelait à une contre mobilisation à
chaque fois qu'un mouvement des
syndicats de police en france va venir
bafouée va venir salir la mémoire de nos
morts repeindre le visage de un homme
mort de 1 à nos frères mot reviendra
encore plus nombreux et ils ont reculé
aujourd'hui on peut appeler ça comme une
victoire c'est une victoire pour nous
que le fait que alliance ne viennent pas
sur place pour repeindre ne serait-ce
que même une lettre des policiers se
sont même regrouper à bobigny devant la
préfecture de seine-saint-denis pour
protester contre ce qu'ils considèrent
être une stigmatisation
nous sommes rassemblés aujourd'hui de
l'indignation que les policiers de saint
louis en découvrant cette fresque où
l'amalgamé été fait entre racisme
violence avec ce terme violences
policières
c'est ce que nous ont ils déjà depuis
plusieurs fois il n'y a pas de racisme
institutionnalisé au sein des forces de
l'ordre il n'y a pas de violence
institutionnelle et 6e au sein des
policiers cela montre qu' il ya un
contexte défavorable et dit pas question
de rester dans ce contexte l'appoint
cette fresque elle est encore différente
des autres parce qu'il faut savoir quand
même qu'elle a été cautionnée par un
maire et en plus sur un bâtiment public
donc un parti du monde dont elle est
serein bâtiments publics et cautionnés
par un maire est que ce maire est
soi-disant en tout cas elle est élue au
premier tour et lui la république
je ne pense pas
qui va pouvoir entre lui même s'en
sortir comme ça deux manifestations
concomitante qui viennent un peu plus
marquée la fracture entre forces de
l'ordre et mouvements antiracistes et
violences policières
chacun manifeste de son côté depuis plus
de trois semaines dans l'attenté d'une
prise de position claire de l'exécutif
sur le sujet
[Musique]